till wie sieht es bei dir aus hat die
polizei auch dort alles noch im griff
und vor allem ist die stimmung noch
einigermaßen entspannt
also hier haben sich seit dem morgen
menschen versammelt zu einer
spontanversammlung die allerdings nicht
genehmigt ist die polizei hat immer
wieder per lautsprecher aufgefordert den
ort zu verlassen masken zu tragen
abstand zu halten
daran halten sich wenige manche haben
sich so spaß masken aufgesetzt hamburg
zwar die nase hängen unterhosen über den
mund gezogen und es gab auch schon
einige reden eben sprach ein
fdp-abgeordneter hansi müller der
zunächst davor warnte dass es sei denn
es sei ja wie 1933 also wie kurz vor der
machtergreifung der nazis was die
regierung da machen um dann
antisemitische versprühten zu verbreiten
dass das die finanzeliten hinter den
corona maßnahmen strecke die pharmalobby
also ist ein einfaches volk jetzt hast
du gerade gesagt die polizei immer
wieder dazu aufgefordert den platz zu
räumen weil die demonstration nicht
angemeldet ist werden denn jetzt schon
schritte eingeleitet damit die menschen
dann hier den platz vor dem
brandenburger tor rund herum räumen oder
sind es bisher nur die
lautsprecheransagen gewesen
[Musik]
es wurden einzelne leute abgeführt also
unter anderem der sogenannte holz lehrer
dass ein bekannter antisemitischer
berlin
der wurde abgeführt dann ein mann der
eine spontane ein spontan gottesdienst
abhalten wollte das ist so eine taktik
der querdenker demonstranten immer dann
ein gottesdienst anzumelden weil den
dürfe man ja nicht störend erst dann von
jona und den wahl gesprochen dann aber
auch schnell wieder davon dass es ja wie
1933 sei also die polizei macht ja noch
nichts allerdings sehen wir jetzt warum
es sind auch jetzt wahrscheinlich ein
partner aus leute hier
ich glaube die können das auch gar nicht
wollen jetzt also
um das räumt müsste man halo studiums
und das so rein bräuchte man
wahrscheinlich ein großes
polizeiaufgebot das auch gerade seien
einige menschen wurden abgeführt wir
müssen dazu sagen dass die verhaftung
die gerade erwähnt worden ist des
fdp-politikers noch nicht bestätigt ist
also das bisher nur berichte über
soziale netzwerke dort müssen wir noch
auf eine bestätigung warten aber
trotzdem sagt uns noch etwas mehr zu den
menschen die du dort gerade siehst du
hast schon darüber gesprochen was auf
der bühne für kundgebungen stattfinden
aber was für ein gefühl hast du wer hat
sich dort jetzt alles versammelt was
sind das für menschen also wähle ich
weiß auf ungefähr 15 solchen
demonstration
es ist immer ehrlich es sind leute da
die würde man dem aussehen nach er so
einem öko hippie spektrum zuordnen mit
dreadlocks allerdings glauben auch die
daran meistens dass die rothschilds
hinter den corona maßnahmen stecken also
es ist eine bunte menge es kommen auch
immer mehr dazu über den durch den
tiergarten den kann die polizei offenbar
gar nicht absperren und dies ist auch
aus ganz deutschland gekommen ich habe
gesprochen er ist aus nürnberg gekommen
das sind durchaus sachsen da es ist aus
ganze die leute hierher gekommen um
gegen die krone maßnahmen der regierung
zu demonstrieren
da sie hat glauben dass die regierung
group ist und vom westen gesteuert wird
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren